thank you everybody for for joining and
i know we just hit the top of the hour
so
welcome to the data science hangout
i know it's a bunch of familiar familiar
faces here but anybody who's joining for
the first time
welcome
this is an open space for the whole data
science community
current and aspiring data science
leaders
to really connect and chat about some of
the more human centric questions around
data science leadership
we really
i'm just going to mute people if there's
a little bit of background noise but we
really want to create spaces where
everybody can participate and and hear
from everyone
so you can jump in live and ask
questions you can put questions in the
chat
and we also have a slido link where you
can ask anonymous questions too
and so if you don't want to be a part of
the recording that's a great way to ask
questions too
because we will share this up to youtube
as well for anybody who missed it
but with that i am so excited to be
joined by my co-host for today jairus
singh
jairus is a director of quantitative
analysis at pandora
and jairus i'd love to turn it over to
you and just have you introduce yourself
and maybe start off by sharing a bit
about your team and the work that you do
yeah thanks rachel thanks for uh having
me today really excited for this um
so
i lead a team of three we're
quantitative analysts um and what's a
little unusual is that we're embedded in
a finance team and as a quick aside when
i first joined i was very skeptical of
being on a data team sort of embedded in
the finance org um just because they're
not historically known for i think
putting as much emphasis on data or the
right emphasis on data um relative to
sort of other orgs that that may have
more of a history of doing so but it's
actually worked out really really well
for us so um you know the way i view the
team is that we have three sort of
pillars that we're responsible for one
is reporting so what happened and this
is all the metrics that pandora cares
about that informs its financial model
so it would be users it would be how
much people are listening what platforms
are they listening on what are the
demographics of listeners all of these
have impacts on what we pay for spinning
the tracks or
um
you know the revenue that we can make
against people when they're listening on
the free tier from advertisements or you
know the propensity to join in trial and
then eventually subscribe so
that's first pillar is reporting second
is forecasting what does the future hold
um we do that using a lot of r um and we
try to rely on algorithmic and automated
techniques as best as possible but
realize that like they can't do
everything for you so there are times
where you know you need sort of human in
the loop style modeling where someone
has to look at it and say okay i'm
getting information from this team
saying they're going to change their
strategy and we need to make sure that
we're not relying entirely on an
algorithm that is not aware of sort of
that that change that's that's coming um
and then the last pillar i'd say is
data-driven decision making so
we have a wealth of information about
our users if we're going to go out and
do marketing or special deals um with
you know it could be a telecom company
or a device manufacturer we want to
understand the most we can about the
sort of users they're going to bring in
or the deal terms so we can use our
knowledge of pandora's data to come up
with a very refined estimate of what we
think would happen under those under
those deals
cool i'm trying to think of myself as a
pandora user like in the app itself is
there something that
maybe the data science team has worked
on that i would see as a user directly
yeah so
um my team is mostly dealing with like
business metrics i would say so there's
not a lot of stuff we've done where it'd
be like oh i i worked on that um it's
more like every time you go and engage
with the app it's like we're trying to
predict how much we think you're going
to use it and sort of the potential you
have towards the business um ltv as well
is important but uh yeah you know we're
not selecting the next song so good to
kind of level set for this discussion
before i get questions about about that
yeah
thanks cheers for the for the intro
while we're asking for
a few questions from the audience and
waiting for those to come in
um i'd love to hear
about something that you're most excited
about in regards to data science
as you look forward to 2022
yeah i guess like generally in the space
what i'm seeing is and this is from sort
of a
some data groups that i'm in and just
reading blog posts is that data folks i
think they know they have a lot to offer
to the table but they're not always in
the room where decisions are being made
and they're not always able to inform
those decisions in the way that i think
they can and should
and what i see is the space sort of
maturing in that like i i personally
believe that data folks are going to get
more ownership over things that sort of
should be in their purview but aren't
necessarily at all companies some
companies are doing this very well where
they're using data where
data can help but i think not all
companies are on that stage of maturity
so i'm expecting sort of more maturity
from the space where
people are getting more sophisticated
about using data
when sort of applicable and to throw out
a company example that i've heard you
know really great things about in the
past and seeing hillary parker talk from
when she was there would be stitch fix
right so uh the way she kind of
presented them is that anything that can
be informed by like the data scientist
skill set uh well or better than what
you would get you know believing that as
um
someone else's decision who doesn't have
that skill set um that's being put in
the data team's hands so i thought that
was a really cool way of framing it and
i think more companies are going to be
moving that direction
awesome thank you i see arafat just
asked a question in the chat
and asked that i read it out loud and so
just want to say if anybody uses the
zoom chat and you want me to read it out
loud just put a little star at the end
so we know
um but airf asks could you share some
more detail about the project um
that you shared earlier or refer to a
resource or book
yeah of course um so human in the loop
is sort of this framework that says
um you can rely on you know any
automated system or algorithms to
generate some of a result but ultimately
a human has to be in the loop somewhere
at some stage right um verifying the
output changing it is necessary and is
is basically able to improve upon the
system if it were a computer alone or a
human alone so i can give some examples
of that and another one's going to come
from stitch fix i feel like i i work
there even though i don't but they have
some really cool use cases so the first
one i'll give is from our world right
where um we're using a lot of time
series techniques to forecast the future
and time series technique is you know if
it's univariate we'll just look at uh
historical data you know how has this
been trending what is expected
seasonality and it'll extrapolate that
forward so that makes sense when the
future state of the world is sort of
structurally similar to what we've
experienced in the past but if we were
to make you know a change and it's an
anticipated change that's where the
human has to get involved so an example
i'll give you is we were growing a
certain platform on the um on the
service you know pretty quickly over
time and it looks like it was a
predictable series but we tried to make
some changes to the user experience
there that we thought would actually
dampen growth they would have you know
an adverse effect on on growth going
forward now the model has no idea that
that's happening right there was no way
for us to sort of pass that in so we
create sort of what we would expect to
happen under you know the old regime and
then we layered in assumptions we got
about the new one and sorry for being
vague but i shouldn't probably go into
too much more detail so that's where
it's like you're accounting for the fact
that the algorithm doesn't know this
change is happening in the future and
you use an alternate set of data and
assumptions to do that tweak um a really
cool stitch fixed example i heard is
when they're actually selecting clothes
for folks so there's a lot of feedback
that people can give on you know prior
sets of clothes they've gotten
which a computer may or may not be good
at really understanding so if the nlp
side of their business isn't you know
fantastic it may not realize like okay
this person's okay getting pants but
like
they still want some but they don't want
it always and a human can do a good job
of saying okay maybe i should send pants
and a kit every other kid or every every
third or something
so it's an area which you would not
expect whatever algorithms you have to
perform well a human has to intervene
and and um kind of adjust what you would
get and you get a better sort of outcome
with that um in terms of resources i'm
not sure if it's addressed in this book
but it's one of our favorites um it's by
rob hendeman
and it's on forecasting uh if you go to
otecs.org it's actually available for
free there forecasting principles and
practice um that's what my team relies
on a lot for a lot of the work that
we've done
i think tori maybe shared that book
earlier as well oh gotcha being one
that's really helpful too
um that's interesting about stitch fix
too because i i use stitch fix and i am
one of the people giving that feedback
and they make it seem like it is a human
interacting with you on that
um there was an anonymous question
oh sorry you go ahead frank thanks
thanks rachel i'm going to pop in and
just add another recommendation from a
previous one of our calls
who paul from kentucky i forget his last
name
but when paul was talking he recommended
prediction machines
and i recently finished that book and
that was heavy on
there's kind of an economics twist with
how do humans work in the future with
algorithms as forecasting improves so
that's another i think really solid
recommendation prediction machines
awesome
i um i went through a few of the
recordings to write out some of the
books that have been mentioned in the
past and
we are working on getting better at
sharing all this information that's
being shared here so i know someone had
asked earlier too about how do we know
like who's speaking which week as well
um and we're working on creating a site
for that so you can see all the
resources shared and clips and stuff so
more to come on that
um but there was an anonymous question
at jairus around how did you get into
data science and
what specifically attracted you to your
current role
yeah that's a good question um
i guess i would say like i started in
college that this would be the beginning
of the journey like studying economics
and mathematics and it's funny like you
see a lot of data science concepts
covered then but they weren't branded as
data science in in school um i guess
we're behind on on the branding when it
comes to those things so i feel like i
was picking up the techniques there and
my first role was in um economic
consulting which is a very esoteric area
but it had to do with um you know it was
in the litigation space companies sewing
companies companies doing governments
government suing companies and trying to
understand like what were the actual uh
damages associated with wrongdoing and
was there wrong doing and you could rely
on econometric analysis to do that um
but still this is not this is not data
science and i think where i made the
leap into data science was while i was
doing that work um
where i think i got most interested and
motivated was was when i started
learning how to do functions i think
that's where it really clicked for me of
like you could write a piece of code
that makes your ability to do this in
the future much much easier and i can
make my life easier and i started to
basically talk to friends who were
going into data science from my network
and realize like that is a space in
which that sort of attitude gets
rewarded so it's like okay i'm
interested in this i'm excited by this
let's start to find jobs um
that like like reward that which i think
is broadly the data science space right
so
um
i yeah i made the jump into tech and
started working on picking up the skills
and i've been really fortunate to have
sort of a series of folks and this was a
long time ago so um i think it was
easier to say like hey i know this
language but like i'll learn this one if
you need me to and and i had you know a
few lucky breaks that enabled me to to
get where i am and i'm obviously really
appreciative of that so that's how i
ended up in this space
that's awesome thank you
i i see there's a question earlier
around hiring too and i know we wanted
to dive deeper
into this topic as well um jairus was on
an earlier webinar on hiring best
practices
but the question was what skill sets do
you look for when hiring
technically and also personality wise
yeah
yeah that's a it's a tough question um
so i'm gonna answer specifically for my
team at pandora what like what we do and
hopefully this is helpful um
don't necessarily
extrapolate this to like all of the data
science ecosystem it's obviously very
broad and people look for different
things
but
what i look for at the technical level
is somebody has to be sort of like maybe
facile is the best word they have to be
very comfortable with uh i think the
common coding concepts that are going to
pop up on the job and i want them to
sort of proactively motivate right i
don't necessarily want to be the person
that says like you should write a
function here right like that the person
should be comfortable enough with those
concepts to sort of motivate them in
their day-to-day work
on the personal side what is tricky for
us is that you know we end up working
quite a bit with stakeholders and very
early on when i hire people i may have
them in the room with stakeholders alone
like obviously i'm there to guide but
the ideal is to like get them at the
point where they're communicating well
and presenting well where they can
handle that themselves and then they can
also sort of scope the sorts of
questions that they get or or you know
follow-up requests that they get from
the stakeholders so ideally i want to
get someone who says okay you know i see
you're asking for this but if i
understand your problem correctly like
i'd rather do this i think this is
actually the thing that's going to solve
it for you
so people who are able to do that and
what i found is that you have folks who
sometimes are very good at the technical
side but they're not as good at the
other sort of skills that we're looking
for and vice versa so
when we do our interviewing we kind of
try to emphasize both and we understand
that you're not going to be you know
necessarily like 10 out of 10 on both
but we really do need a healthy balance
because otherwise it's very difficult to
sort of do what we do um
other you know beneficial personality
traits i look for in addition to
communication are and this sort of comes
out during the interview is
interest in the sort of problems that we
work on i think it's really good to
signal that during an interview um
and
what i found is that folks who do that
during the interview process you know
tend to continue to do it on the job i
haven't seen very many good actors so
when they're like oh you know do you all
look at this data or do you do that or
have you thought about this those folks
tend to do very well in the role because
they bring that sort of brainstorming
mentality to the role and and what i
found is they're able to solve things in
ways that you know i i wouldn't have
thought of other team members wouldn't
have thought of it really does help out
a lot so that's another thing that i
look for um versus the sort of passive
applicant who's like yeah i don't know
how to view like what do you guys do
i'll just i'll just continue to sort of
implement that
definitely i think that was a tip that
you had mentioned in the webinar too
just making sure to actually
research the
like field that you're in to make sure
that you're aware of what are the kinds
of problems that they're facing
totally yeah uh i i'd say that's
probably the most like common piece of
advice i i give folks i work with a boot
camp as well so i do calls with folks
who are looking for jobs and then i had
one yesterday just with a friend in my
network and that's one of the things i
say is like understand the business um
just because i mean obviously it gives
you stuff to talk about during the
interview you know when it comes to like
small talk but also like one of the most
common data science questions i see is
like okay what metrics would you look at
if you were working here and a lot of
folks are very caught off guard because
they're like i didn't realize i had to
kind of solve that beforehand like i was
hoping you would tell me and then we
would do a problem on that so i think
it's nice to sort of bring that to the
table and it makes any follow-up
questions a lot easier because you're
already framing them in the context of
you know the the place you're applying
i really like that you said you put new
hires into the room with the
stakeholders as well to
like start
back back and forth communication
and i see there was a question that
asked how do you build confidence and
communication and presentation skills
within people
yeah so
what i would recommend is have like a a
mentor at your company it doesn't have
to be your manager but somebody who has
those skills and reach out to them and
say
i would love to you know go over a
presentation with you or just invite
them to your meeting sometimes that's a
great way to to you know cheat at
getting feedback oh i need you you know
i need you in the room to see this even
though you may not necessarily but
someone who who has those skills who can
sort of guide you on it because that's
what i try to do
for my team just having the i guess it
came from the consulting background i
don't know where it came from but um
wherever i picked it up you know i do
think that's one of the advantages i
have and of course being in management
my uh technical skills of atrophied so
they're much better at that side of
things um but just be able the ability
to make myself available and give them
feedback before important meetings or
sit in the meetings and guide them and
then also give them the heads up that's
happening because not everyone likes to
be caught off guard while say okay like
you know let's move on to this topic
because i think someone's interested or
can you explain that more i don't think
everyone got it stuff like that and over
time i think that reinforcement um
really helps out because eventually it's
kind of like training wheels like you
won't need them anymore you know you've
gotten enough practice with an advocate
or a mentor that you can do it yourself
i guess one thing to add on it is
data scientists i think on average tend
to overestimate how much everyone else
knows about data science so if you're
like am i over explaining it or under
explaining it odds are you're under
explaining it and and again depending on
who's in the room you know again we're
thinking like stakeholder management
folks who generally don't have a
background in in the data side of things
um i would err on the side of over
explanation and then always give them an
out right you say if you already know
this or i'm being redundant i will skip
the slide or skip this section and we
can move on
that's really helpful too
and
just want to say again if anybody wants
to ask question live
robert is teaching me to be a big
proponent of the raising hand on zoom as
well we're trying that in internal
meetings or just unmuting yourself as
well and i can take that as as raising
your hand
but ena i see you had asked the question
in the the chat
that you want me to read out
and it was has the pandemic wreaked
havoc your time series models some weeks
back elaine mcvay
discussed about how difficult time
series modeling became in the cpg sector
are you experiencing this as well
we did yeah it's uh the effect is much
more muted now but at the beginning of
the pandemic there was
um
you know a huge change in the way in
which people listen to pandora
that of course is now you know when
extrapolated forward having a lot of
problems so what i was kind of proud of
was our team has you know the knowledge
of how our algorithms work not only do
we implement them but we understand how
they work and we were able to very
quickly identify like look the outputs
of these are not going to make sense and
so we had to sort of pull alternative
models online which i think we did
within
two weeks or so which i'm pretty
impressed by um and we you know we we
had probably some silly manual model we
were using like in between then um in
order to account for it um but i was
really proud of the way in which we sort
of pivoted quickly and i would say like
if you're dealing with business side
data you should consider that a part of
your job because again
there are folks who place a lot of
emphasis on you know can i put these
things into production and can i run
them but if you're not making sure that
they're resilient to things like this or
you don't have a plan for how you would
fix it i realize not everyone wants to
plan like possible pandemic into like
every month of the work that they do but
if you don't have some way of pivoting
quickly you know in the eyes of the
folks you work for they're like wow that
person's like not really doing their job
and you know we pay them so much because
they have all these skills but like in
in some ways you want to be
resilient to these sorts of changes so i
was really happy with how we dealt with
it it is still causing problems on
models that
our partner teams work on just because
you know we've decided we want to
interpolate data and and fill it in um
but due to the nature in the structure
it's just like a lot to put there and so
we're trying to figure out like
how much effort should we put into this
sort of interpolation and how much
should we just sort of you know hand
wave and and maybe put less
sophistication behind what we what we
put in the historicals but yeah it did
affect us a lot um so great great
question ian
how did you know
how did you know when your output wasn't
making sense was it all accuracy metrics
yeah that's the way we determined it and
accuracy for us um you know we have a
good idea of how accurate like we should
be and then what's sort of abnormal
and we entered abnormality pretty
quickly um so what i i can tell you all
about pandora usage is like a lot of it
we've found is associated with routine
and so when routines get disrupted you
see large changes in how people listen
and we saw that happening in march wiz
shutdowns and with panic buying you know
you're you're buying you're buying
toilet paper you're not you may not
remember to put on pandora in your car
when you're stressed out so we we did
see that and yeah accuracy is is what we
use and it was just like this seasonal
kink
that you know you would not expect but
for you know major disruption happening
so that's that's how we saw it um it was
kind of interesting to see like it
happened kind of at different places
throughout the nation and we tried to
line that up with sort of how serious
folks were taking it um but the end of
the day that was kind of a cute analysis
there's nothing we can do with it you
know where uh
a really bad ongoing joke we had is like
in that first two weeks it was like
unless you're developing the vaccine
like this is not going to change so we
need to just adapt sort of um what we're
looking at you know we're not going to
be able to do anything to to sort of
solve against this while people have
much greater concerns on their minds
i know you mentioned the sirius xm and
stitcher side as well so i was curious
like being one big happy family if the
data science teams ever like work
together share
insights as well like i was thinking
with the pandemic did people start
listening to podcasts more versus music
at certain times
yeah um
there were
small changes in what people listen to
and the most obvious one is like health
or news podcasts saw spike um
and it would have happened naturally but
also obviously like as a company we
started to promote those right we
figured they were top of mind so
you know they did well both by i think
being relevant and by the company
realizing and this is again human in the
loop right you need somebody uh i
believe it was a marketing led
initiative to say like this is something
that i think is culturally relevant
people want to know about so you know
the algorithm is not magically going to
surface this podcast which has not been
as popular lately and so they sort of
pushed it um in terms of like the type
of music people listen to
we had a very i honestly i don't think
the evidence was really good but someone
was definitely pushing the like people
want to like they're panicky they want
calming music and so they were looking
at like oh this like you know this calm
genre that we have tagged just like
increasing a little bit but uh
i i don't know if i would have
necessarily made that case it fit with
the narrative of what was going on but
i'm not sure it was actually showing up
or if it was just noise
cool thank you
fritz i see you asked a question in the
chat and i'd love to turn it over to you
to have you ask it live that's okay
i could read it as well
um so the oh he said you said you don't
have a microphone i'm happy to read it
and the question was what is the
technological environment like at
pandora how do you deploy models that
your team develops
yeah so we're on google cloud platform
for all of the sort of raw and upstream
data that my team relies on and the data
engineers get it there for us so that's
where we start you know working with
pandora data and we'll do aggregations
there you know we have to handle
ourselves sometimes logic needs to be
applied to
classifying various platforms we don't
want to deal with the the laundry list
that they have
so from there
we will get it into bigquery or a
postgres server we've just used for a
long time and we've not migrated our
jobs over to bigquery and then we'll
connect to that with our studio so we're
using our studio either server for sort
of the the bigger projects that we have
and then we'll use or if rs connect is
needed for a shiny dashboard and then
sometimes a personal laptop just when it
like doesn't really matter how much
firepower you need um so we'll use sort
of both instances and and personal can
also be good for depth sometimes if if
you want to use it for that
and then for visualization or end
product you know sometimes it's just
dumping the data back into something
like bigquery or postgres sometimes it's
um you know a csv that other folks in
finance can ingest and use in excel or
something that can be uploaded to
hanaplan which is how we manage a lot of
our financial reporting um or a shiny
dashboard is what we sort of default to
and then we've inherited some work
that's in tableau so we'll do that as
well
and what i would say is the way i like
to explain it to
stakeholders who are used to working
with folks doing a lot of manual
reporting is i say like one or zero
click
to send this report to give them an idea
of uh you know you may have folks
putting together stuff in excel and
pulling manually from different sources
we're able to sort of create this whole
sort of pipeline or ecosystem for a lot
of the problems that we do that require
one click or zero clicks the one clicks
usually just to check to make sure
everything makes sense before you you
send the report out um
yeah so that's our ecosystem
thank you
bruno i i see you had a question in the
chat too can i
pass the mic over to you
in case people are tired of just hearing
me talk and release
i see you've unmuted but
we couldn't hear you yet there you go
yep i'm here great all right thanks for
doing this uh a question from your
experience if you have to sell a data
science project in an organization what
is the most likely to succeed
an absolute baller representation of
resolve but average predictive power
or
an academic paper level long-form
presentation you know like no image
nothing
but
now some predictive power
which has the most uh
value to executives
yeah i'll kick it back to you bruno so
when you say to sell a data science
project do you mean something that's
been completed and you're trying to get
credit for it or it's like here's
something i want to go out and and do
so say you you build the team you are
your data scientist because it's the
buzzword of the week and then yeah the
executive spent a lot of money to build
this team and then you you come back
with results let's say one or two years
down the line
uh to justify the reason for your
existence right does that makes a major
context
totally yeah so you've been doing a lot
of projects during this time and you
want to communicate sort of the value of
the business to them okay so i will
answer your question and then i'll take
a sort of tangent related to that
question um i would say like the first
thing is it's dependent on who is the
executive that you're presenting to but
by and large at most companies my
experience has been
the executives who hire or green light
data science teams are not well versed
in data science themselves so a lot of i
think the onus is on like management and
leadership and data science to explain
to them the value and
i think you know a good executive is not
going to try and like pick you apart for
not presenting stuff while they care
about ultimately the bottom line usually
um so you know
better results should work but i think
it's the way in which you frame them so
so there's there's the idea of like
making it pretty and making it impactful
um pretty you know the eye bankers are
good at the management consultants are
good at and and execs are used to
working with them and they're used to
seeing things that way but if you were
to do like a summary or output of a
table that shows how much money you're
saving the company through your
optimization efforts and that's in the
millions of dollars uh my let's just say
you don't really need to you know put
that that number in the same font as
everything else in the deck and make
sure it's standardized at the end of the
day i'd say that's what matters so
where i see sort of the yeah dollar
speak i saw you put the chat where i see
this sort of failure in
like
trying to show um how good the data
science team is or how much they're
doing is sometimes they will focus a lot
on you know metrics that we're very
comfortable with and are sort of easier
to calculate and a classic example is we
had a model that had 80 accuracy i made
it 84. but without doing some work to
explain like what is the value of that
to the business um you know executives
can sometimes be skeptical um also like
they may not be well versed in the
problem space so they might say 80 to 84
like that's not very good right like
that doesn't seem like you did a very
good job because they haven't been
working at those problems as long as you
have and understand sort of the
hairiness of them so
um i guess more broadly than just
dollars i would say like speaking the
language that they care about and are
receptive to if you're in people
analytics it might be what are the
things that we've done that have
resulted in employee retention which
again ultimately makes its way down to
dollars but make sure to coach it in
like what they care about what they're
expecting because um
the like way i like to view data science
is you know at the end of the day like
they're hiring us because we have a
skill set it's a tool and it's a tool
being applied to problems of the
business it doesn't matter how fancy
your tool is if it's not solving the the
problems that the business has so uh try
try to view it through through their
lens you know i've tried to do that
throughout my career and um i found you
know that that tends to work that tends
to work well
thank you so much
i'm marking to clip that one i want to
go back in
and now yeah
edit appropriately i know i was around i
was a little all over the place because
i have strong feelings about it and it
actually just reminded me of one
additional thing and now i'm blanking on
maybe i'll remember it while we take the
uh the next one no i mean i mean save
that piece to share it with everybody
yeah that was incredibly helpful
yeah there was a great question earlier
that was what are some small steps
someone can take to become a more
effective data scientist or leader in
this in the long term um it seems like
there's so much to learn and dive into
yeah so to be a leader i'm gonna i'm
gonna um
think about that piece particularly so
like what is the difference between a
good data scientist and a good data
science leader and this relates a little
bit to what bruno was asking so
and i sort of had this as a rude
awakening during my career which was
as a data scientist right a lot of
emphasis is placed on like what are the
tools and techniques that you have you
know why are they better than doing it
manually or doing it under you know
older styles of say like an excel based
report or what have you like what like
why do we need you and why do you do
what you do and so much emphasis was
placed on that um but less so you know
on the communication my manager was
handling it and certainly on like
project scope right it wasn't really my
job to say like this project should
entail this or it should do that or if
we're trying to solve this problem we
should do this obviously i was allowed
to give some feedback but ultimately it
wasn't my call
where i see like data science leadership
like like uh what people who are doing
well in that space you know the skills
they have to develop and they may not be
developing
as an ic or obviously the communication
presentation
being able to understand what are the
needs of their stakeholders and then how
can or can not data solve those problems
so i say can obviously because that's
the job but cant is also really
important as well because if you have a
stakeholder come to you and say we want
to trade a model that does or can you
build a model that does xyz like it's
going to be great and you say yeah i
don't actually see how that's going to
help the business and you can sit down
with them and explain why or say
historically we've you know tried to
develop models here and we haven't had
much success there's nothing i can think
of that i think would do better so
instead of just sitting down and going
and do that
you're the person who has some say
around you know i think this is more
likely to be successful and it actually
advanced the needs of the of the
business and so rachel that totally ties
into what i was saying earlier when you
interview day one or day zero or
negative one depending how you look at
it if you understand the business i
think it makes you much much better able
to to do that um then if you know you
don't really know the inner workings of
it so the idea of proposing here are the
projects i think are most likely to
succeed and then getting people on board
with that um
maybe this is a lazy analogy but it
almost feels somewhat like vc like like
you're a data vc in some ways like i'm
betting on these three projects to
deliver value for the business and like
i need you to buy into them so i can
have someone go out and and do them and
and help us be sort of most successful
i really like explaining it that way
as being like a data vc
first i see just asked another question
in the chat that i'll read out which was
how do you deal with people who feel a
threat from machine models those who are
afraid
of having their jobs displaced by data
models
yeah that's a tough one i haven't had a
ton of experience with that
but i would say right now the state
we're at for a lot of sort of data
informed
projects at a company is that human in
the loop is a great way to go and if a
human is in the loop then you're not
really threatening someone's job the
idea is i think that you are
advancing the value that they offer
because you're giving them tools that
they can use right in order to do their
job better
that is not always the case so it's sort
of dependent on how things are
structured you can't tell someone oh
it's human in the loop and then cut them
out entirely but for a lot of things
that we see and i mentioned that example
earlier where like we knew given the
cultural climate and the global pandemic
people would be more interested in
health and news related to that than
history we need smart good marketers to
say okay i'm going to let the algorithms
pick you know certain things to put in
front of people but i need to reserve
this space for something that i
personally am willing to bat you know
folks are really interested in are going
to increase engagement so that's how
they work with it i know i gave the
stitch fixed example earlier as well
again that's not always the case it's
kind of a cop-out to say like oh
everything will be human in the loop and
we'll all be fine but in general what
happens with you know the progress we
make on on the machine side is that we
kind of let people add more value
because it's displacing sort of the
easiest tasks again this is on average
not always but that's what i've been
seeing you know not just in my company
but at others as well so i would say
it's not so much threatening to you know
your job as a whole but it does mean
that if you're somebody who's been doing
a job without a machine learning model
you need to understand how do i work
with this thing because you know it's
not going to go away
i know on
previous weeks we've also talked about
the importance of testing and a b
testing and how sometimes
we don't always do that or give it
enough time to actually consider it a
test yeah and i'm just curious like
thinking of
human in the loop project or aspect
and having people recommend certain
things like oh
during the pandemic people will look at
health
podcasts or something
um how do you kind of push back if
that's not actually the case or how do
you test that out and have that
conversation
um so the idea like is having
a human like someone intervening like
better than than the alternative
or if somebody feels strongly that
for example they're going to listen to
health related things when that's not
actually the case how do you communicate
that gotcha yeah so this is where we get
into the fuzzy side of things very
quickly right because um when you have
you know a well-behaved algorithm a
recommendation system right you can say
with some confidence like here's how
much i expect people
to to like whatever content i'm giving
them we have a long history of how well
this is done and we expect it to perform
more or less just as well in the future
right
and so when you have somebody you know
human saying well i want to change this
or i want to change that it really has
to be done case by case because there's
nothing in our framework that says oh
you know retune the algorithm but for a
pandemic right we do not have the
ability to do that so um they really
always get dealt on a case-by-case basis
but rachel you raise a really good point
that i do know there are stakeholders
who probably put
too much um
they put too much uh faith in the
machines and they don't do enough of
that alternatively
alternatively you have people who do the
opposite right who always want to
override the machines and they do such
their own detriment um i'd say i agree
with you that like a b testing these
approaches is a great idea to sort of
create a historical record of like how
good are our overrides but the tricky
thing about them sometimes is that
you're not always able to do an abe test
so you can't always actually figure out
like what is the utility of of you know
having someone doing this intervention
versus just letting the machine
make its recommendations but yeah i i
would do it if possible sometimes it's
tricky or not possible um but if it is
possible you can what i would do is i
would try to create a history of you
know this person has tried to override
recommendations they did it in this
period in this period and over time they
either you know batted above average or
below average
and we can use that information to
inform should we do more intervention in
the future
that's really helpful thank you
see there's great a great question i had
missed earlier just scrolling up um that
was how do you advocate for the pandora
data team being involved in decision
making
yeah so this is where
being in finance has been hugely
beneficial um and i mentioned i was
skeptical when i first joined because
finance teams don't you're not generally
associated with data prowess no offense
finance teams or maybe offense taken so
you all can you know go out and get
better and prove me wrong um
but
being embedded in finances helps with
that hugely because at the end of the
day the decisions that we are making are
coached in those terms terms that
everybody cares about obviously the cfo
and the ceo as well and so once you've
got that framing down of like we're
trying to understand um
how you know if this initiative proposed
initiative will be break even or we want
to understand what's the utility of
missing our forecasts like how bad is
one percent miss and accuracy how bad is
two percent like what are the downstream
effects of making these mistakes um
that has been hugely beneficial so i
also find that the finance problems are
generally a little more well scoped and
this is for better or for worse it's
just very easy to understand like yeah
we're doing breakeven on this or what
have you it's a little trickier when it
gets to someone like product where you
say well we think we should build this
do we have data to support it you know
sometimes the answer is no but you have
to go out and build it anyways so um i
would say the advocacy that i had to do
over time was not me trying to convince
people of my team's worth it was more
just like
producing hopefully a drum beat constant
drum beat of of wins and then showing
people like look this is what we do and
how we do it and you need to trust us
and involve us in the process and we've
had times where folks have tried to go
around us and try to sort of sell a
decision without our involvement and
you know our our leaders have always
backed us up and said like no you need
to involve you know this this group or
the finance team or the group within the
finance team to make sure that that's
the right decision
awesome thank you
i just want to
check that i haven't missed anyone's
question yet so far and would love to
have people
unmute or come on live too
yeah i guess what you all are thinking i
might add um i do expect more
organizations to start embedding data
people in the finance org or if there's
like a
hybrid org right so you have the data
org we're we're decentralized but if you
have the hybrid org so data org but
everyone has sort of different groups
that they support um like dotted lines
too
ultimately that reporting into the cfo i
think is really powerful
and i've been seeing it more often i'm
just talking to folks in this space and
i think that's going to become more
popular so brian said in the chat uh
backing you know the finance team can be
very helpful because uh there's power
there uh i suspect going forward you
know you're going to have more and more
finance teams looking to build out data
folks under them
robert i see you have your hand raised
can i turn it over to you
yeah
sorry my camera's off i'm getting a bite
to eat but great stuff uh so far on that
topic and this is something i've been
thinking about personally what
what should data scientists or really
just anyone who doesn't work in a
financial function what are some basic
things that they should understand about
finance within uh
a business or assets that they should
learn how to comfortably kind of um
look at
yeah that's a great question robert i
would say the basics will get you a long
way so
you know revenue cost and then profit
which is which is sort of revenue minus
cost um and then
specifically like how does your company
generate those revenues how are those
costs generated against those revenues
and then what are the ways in which your
company is looking to sort of change
over time or improve over time to
improve those things and then the last
question that you can answer right is
how can i use data to
to do that and then that's you kind of
doing the job but it is interesting how
many you know folks you talk to with a
very strong data skill set who
you know as i mentioned earlier like how
do you put a value on accuracy
improvement so they've built their whole
careers around i'm going to learn models
that can improve you know the accuracy
over whatever historical thing you were
using and that's me doing a really good
job but in the eyes of the stakeholder
if there isn't someone to do the
translation of like here's what those
accuracy benefits mean in terms of
dollars and it doesn't have to be
dollars today it could be dollars
tomorrow um it's really difficult to
sort of make that case of what it's
worth so those are the the big ones i
would say
the the thing i would add is like you
don't need to go too far down the rabbit
hole in terms of like
for me i guess it's it's on the margins
which is most important for us right so
like the marginal revenue of doing
something the marginal cost i have not
spent a lot of time worrying about like
how do you look at like head count and
finance against them like it's just not
really a part of the job and i think you
can skip over that because it's not
something you would be usually applying
you know your data prowess to but often
it's on the margin so you sell one
additional uh product or in our case you
get someone to listen you know 10
additional hours on the ad supported
tier like what is that worth
thank you jairus brunoise you have your
hand raised as well
yeah just to come back second question
uh what difficult part of your role
would you rather a computer do instead
of you so you know you allocate your
time during the day
there's stuff that's enjoyable there's
other stuff that you know why i'm still
doing this
so
what is this part that the human process
you find suboptimal
okay and is this something like in an
ideal world or like this is the next
thing i'd want someone to go at and
develop because those are very different
answers no no yeah ideal world like the
the job of the future
job of the future yeah um
what i would love for and this is almost
this is goofy but you know
there's always more ideas than there is
actual capacity to do work at an
organization is what is what i've always
found you know and everybody loves to
bring ideas to the table and say hey
that oh i mentioned that a while ago you
know like i'm so great um but there's
not that many people can actually sit
down and implement them right you always
have more ideas so
in an ideal world i would love a little
like email scraper to
to go through some of the suggestions i
get and say something like hey we did
that before and it didn't work or like
hey we did that before and we're doing
it right now like that's not a new thing
it's already happening or that's a great
idea let's do that and that's a great
idea we'll probably be one percent of
the emails i get
but yeah you know it's it's the value of
institutional knowledge and you can
argue once you know a computer does that
i would not have a job but it is
frustrating to say like yeah that's how
our things work or no like that's not
possible of that sort of you know
sorting of all the various initiatives
that we get pitched um that would be
nice and i think there may be some low
hanging fruit because the same ideas do
get recycled every few years and so to
just say like hey you know it's almost a
slack bot like we tried that like check
this wiki page on the results
i hope that wasn't too silly
i like that idea automatically taking it
from your email either putting it in
your to-do list or not
yeah yeah
but especially for stuff that we've done
or already tried because people love to
think that like oh no one's thought of
this before i'm revolutionizing things
like no we've done that before and it
either worked and we continued to do it
or or it didn't and we're not going to
do it again
yeah
frank i see you have your hand raised
too
oh you might be muted
all right um
so uh
jairus i was just wondering and maybe
you mentioned this in your intro in the
first five minutes if i missed it i
apologize but do you have
hobbies or passions outside of your data
science work at pandora that you
use for
creative ideas or inspirational thinking
or just ways of looking at the world
that you then apply back in to your work
um
yes to the first half i haven't quite
figured out how i want to apply it yet
but i think the applications are are
there um and i guess i'll share like a
cute example of me
doing you know an explore exploit like
algorithm manually so i love cooking um
and i'm cooking like kind of non-stop um
and so i do it every day even if i'm
really tired i find energy for it so
it's you know a very sticky hobby that i
find really rewarding um and you know
there are a lot of cooking analogies
about like the data science process but
for me i think what has been
um
most useful about understanding like
data or maybe like
technology more broadly is like there's
all these sort of things in the cooking
process that are kind of tweakable and i
personally think the modern way in which
people interact with recipes doesn't
really account for that and so what i've
been playing on the side and i don't
know if this is a data thing or like an
app or something that i'm not smart
enough to build is like how do you
better represent that in a way that
people who are either very good chefs or
very good data people can you know
better interact with this system so as
an example i'll give you is like i've
tried a bunch of different ways of
making the same recipe but when you go
to a website like you just see the one
that someone did that they considered to
be best and you don't really see
information about like how many things
do they have to do to get here and is
there useful information about those
things because if you read comments in
recipes it's all the uh a policy i have
is read the most upvoted comment and do
what that person says always like your
default should always be do what they
say so it classically like you don't
need that step or like that's too much
salt like do what they say and then you
know adjust the recipe because the
recipe that gets posted on the blog is
like often not final um so i like that a
lot and i'd love to just see the
ecosystem get somewhere where i think
it's accounting for the fact that
everybody's kind of experimenting um so
in two years if i'm working on a startup
and stealth like that's what i'm doing
now you know um but yeah it's a good
question i haven't been able to i think
like
draw tight enough connections with data
uh what i do recommend folks who are
getting into this space to do is i say
you know pick a project you're motivated
about and most people are motivated
about their own data so the two areas i
like to point them to are health and
personal finance again you have to have
some pre you know prior interest in them
but those are great ones because it's
like on the one hand you know do i want
to muck around with an iris data set
even though i don't really know what an
iris looks like or do i want to figure
out where i'm over spending and can i
predict future spend like it's kind of i
think a little more fun and exciting and
tangible
i like how you flipped around right
you're like well i use all these data
science ideas and how i think about the
data science world and apply it to my
passions to get better at my passions
yeah
yeah so maybe it's just like the
overarching style of thinking yeah uh
hugh says github for recipes yes you
that's that's what i'm going for
basically um so stay tuned
awesome i see um olivia had asked a
question in the chat too
that was do you find it more beneficial
to hire generalists or specialists when
a team is first being built for a new
project
yeah good question libby my experience
is
generalist but again like that's me as a
leader saying i know that i am often
unable to predict what future needs of
the team will be
and in order to accept that you need to
you can't hire specialists because uh if
they're specialized in an area that gets
de-emphasized or something um they're
not gonna be as good of a fit as someone
who's you know generalist so my team
hires general us you know obviously it's
it's team dependent um but i mentioned
before right we don't expect you to be
10 out of 10 in any specific thing but
you need to be like seven or eight on a
bunch of things because you are going to
get pulled in different directions and
sort of have to do different parts of
projects um yeah
awesome thank you um rick i see you have
your hand raised as well can i turn over
to you
hey thanks rachel um really great
conversation so far i had a couple
points that i want to mention but one
thing that i wanted to jump in on was
this idea of the cooking and the
um and the data algorithms and i'm a
biologist and we use the same analogy
all the time that working in the
laboratory and doing experiments and
mixing reagents is just like being in
the kitchen at home
but i think the difference is that at
home
when you cook when you read a cookbook
like people don't know
why they're assault or what's the
difference between baking powder and
baking soda for example or how the
humidity in the air affects what you're
cooking but in the laboratory you know
every single reagent and you know
exactly how the concentration is going
to affect the outcome of your experiment
so why do i put this much magnesium in
why what is it doing what is edta and
what all these chemicals and i think
that's the similar thing with with uh
data scientists that they look at okay
just get an answer and just focus on
this metric and the how everything is
connected and the pulleys under the hood
like if i increase this how does that
affect the result i don't think that's
played i mean my impression at least is
that i don't think it's in played and
played enough around with when people
are learning they just learn the ropes
and they don't learn to be playful and
really experiment and see how those
things do
how these affect the results so like
when i teach stuff i try and make me
make like a simulation like make a shiny
app that allows people to just you know
simulate some data and what if i had
this in my data what if i had this
distribution what if i change this
parameter how does that affect the
output at the end to get a more of an
intuitive feeling do you think that
would be something that that can work i
think it would work for cooking as well
as well actually
yeah that so that's a great suggestion
um i have someone on my team who is
really good at that style of thinking
and i am notoriously bad at it um and
the reason i'm bad at it and maybe it's
a good thing is that like if you chase
down all those things like many of them
don't work or are not beneficial um and
in my the way my mind works is like oh
you're gonna waste your time like you
know two percent chance that'll make
sense um but i think it's really
important to have folks on the team who
do have those skills so like we kind of
compliment each other because she'll
come up with a lot of suggestions and
i'll say okay of the 40 you just said in
two minutes let's do like ten of those
but these are the ten i think i have the
most faith in um but i do think that
playfulness is is really important on
the job or just the creativity in
general um because as you mentioned
right you do see people who are just
like just get the metric just get the
answer and i think if you're not
understanding how it fits into the
greater whole right again understand the
business understand your role in the
business and what you're trying to do
you're not you're not going to be
successful
you know again i like analogies like
would you rather have a precise cupcake
or a delicious cupcake right i think i
think we all know which one we'd prefer
yeah
i think what rick's getting at is
that's the scientist part of data
scientists
um
we call them that for two reasons there
is an element of science and
experimentation
uh
and i think what's often left out of the
picture is hypothesis testing and
um you know every
wants to throw out all the statistics
and just go to some auto ml and be done
with it and it's kind of like well you
got to have
some reasonable hypothesis before you
get started otherwise you will as you
say jared you're going to wind up going
down these
rabbit holes and two percent loops and
every and everything else and i think
that's a because i i my background is in
chemistry too and i was involved in
making materials and stuff so
it's just like cooking there is that
creative element but
it's the same thing with data science
modeling like
you know how do we get it a little bit
better or what can we learn from this
last model to make the next one better
i know we're getting to the top of the
hour here but i love this discussion
that's going on so if
anybody has time to stay on definitely
stay here with us um but jairus i also
want to
be respectful of your time and i don't
know if you have a meeting to run to
right after
i don't know either
[Music]
i'm gonna check real quick um
but yeah if anyone has any other
[Music]
cooking or data related things they want
to mention let me just check real quick
there's a few questions um
still coming through from slido two so
i'll just ask um
one quick one
someone said totally out of context but
would be a big help does pandora sponsor
work visas
i don't know i'm sorry i wish i did i
should have that information handy
if you are interested in a role feel
free to reach out on the side yeah
connect on linkedin i can look into it
for you
awesome and hugh i i see you had also
asked a question earlier if you want to
jump in and ask that one
yeah sure thing um so you had mentioned
a little while ago about kind of chasing
some of the stuff you're interested in
like cooking or at work uh you know
making time to focus on something you're
interested in rather than like the
day-to-day work
um i was just curious have you noticed
that paying longer term dividend or uh
paying more dividends in the long term
by kind of chasing your interest or your
passion rather than that work that's
right in front of you
um
yeah so i guess in a world in which like
i'm trading off like do i want to spend
some time in the kitchen or do i want to
do more studying or more work or
something
yeah i would say like for my happiness
and i think for everyone's happiness i
think it's important to
do things that you care about and also
recognize that even if you care very
deeply about something it may not be
healthy to do it all the time um so
there are folks i've seen i have one
friend in the data space who loves it
and it seems like if a hundred percent
of his time were dedicated toward he
would be the happiest clam in in the
entire ocean but most people aren't like
that and i think that's fair to
recognize um you know when i do cook i
i'm not always doing it with the lens of
like how does this help me in the data
world but i think i pull like sort of my
knowledge of the data world to the way
in which i approach my cooking which
which is helpful
yeah at the end of the day i would say
feed your soul and if you
know what your soul wants go do that and
if you don't know what your soul wants
try and figure it out experiment um but
yeah i i don't think i could do the
alternative i'd be very unpleasant to be
around
thank you um i was thinking more in the
context of a work environment too where
say i'm supposed to be
working on forecasts for something you
know that's my long-term you know that's
my current task but i'm really more
interested in chasing
uh deep diving into graph databases or
something else where i have an interest
and really
like long-term
that ends up you know paying uh much
more dividends than if i just chase kind
of the work that's directly in front of
me got it i'm sorry i didn't do a good
job of asking uh earlier no no of course
no thank you that that's helpful so um i
guess it's it's
is the context that like you want to do
the stuff you're passionate about to
eventually get like a role in that area
um
let's get a role with more um
you know i chase your interest at work
uh and uh rather than necessarily just
doing
uh exactly that kind of this is exactly
what i'm supposed to be doing this is
the task i'm assigned to you have to do
a certain amount of that but exploring
your interest as well
uh
long-term kind of chasing some of those
things you're really curious or
passionate about and bringing those into
the work that you do
uh to kind of see the payoff there or do
you see a payoff
yeah totally so the way i've seen i i
have not been great at this myself but
the way i've seen people who do this
well is one they do the core job and
they do it well and they understand sort
of what's me doing you know good job
there's a great job versus an amazing
job and they're generally smart enough
people to pick where on that spectrum
they want to be um so these are usually
very bright people and they say i could
do an amazing job but i'm just going to
do a good job and then i'm going to
invest that remaining 20 of my time or
whatever it is into stuff i care about
and i'm going to do it in a way that i
can sort of spin to my manager or
leadership it's like this has potential
we should look into it and when you do
that and you're doing a good job i found
it's sort of rare for someone to say
like no i don't want you doing that
right because you're you know you might
leave and now they have someone not
doing a good job so i found that that's
the way to sort of make it uh like
politically palatable is to say like
look i'm already doing all the stuff i
need to do but here's where i want to
sing some extra time into
and then you kind of you know coach it
in a way that like is
useful to them so you know research and
testing gets thrown around a lot i want
to research these techniques i think
they might be helpful if you're doing a
good job it's usually easy to sell if
you're not doing a good job at your work
you know it's harder to say well i want
to try this and i want to try that so i
found you know the folks who are really
good are um
folks who again they're kind of picking
the level of effort on the core
responsibilities and then they're just
coming up with a decent pitch for the
stuff they're passionate about and just
tying it to the business in some way
awesome thank you
that's incredible
we used to use the 80 20 rule at a place
that i worked at and i was able to sell
to the other management is like
80 of our work is going to keep the
lights on
and keep the business going but
20 of the work is going to be on what is
the next thing down the road that it's
going to be
um
and understanding that that's a
long-term investment
and it could be as simple as like when i
was working with my junior data
scientist hey i'm going to take a course
in
deep learning for this
you know granted we're not using that in
the group today and everything else but
we might need it down the road and
that's an investment
and
i think as a leader you have to
encourage that and it can't be
you only do it on nights and weekends on
your own time
and so we i used to have an expression
it's friday is my day
um and so i would i would pitch that to
my team members friday's your day
to do something new you just need to
tell me what you're doing and obviously
we got to keep the lights on too and
we'll know you'll know that pretty
quickly if the lights aren't being kept
on um
but it's a way to
uh
orient people to do to grow themselves
otherwise it just it never happens um or
you force people to do it on their own
which is
now you're just putting it all putting
all the learning on them and as a leader
or as an organization you expect to take
everything from them and not give them
anything back and that doesn't really
uh help people grow either
yeah that's great brad i think formally
carving it out and i think that was also
a google thing right like 20 time is the
best way to go i have not been
successful in being able to do that but
um i think it's the nature of sometimes
we get requests that are urgent and you
can't say like this is my time but as a
result i think we've done a lot of the
automation to make sort of what could
take x hours is now maybe even x over
two um and so that frees up a lot of
space for for other stuff that we work
on um and at the end of the day like i
think the pitch is important so you say
you know someone on my team wants to
learn xyz here's the ways in which you
could be helpful and again if you're
doing generally well in your role
leadership's usually happy to just say
yeah go for it
yep and and i understand you're in
finance and i've worked in finance and
everything else and
the other way i tell people to look at
it is if you can't do that
spend spend your first half hour of the
day
doing it so five days a week if you work
from 8 to 8 30 you know you check your
emails make sure the building's not
burning down the whole organization
isn't in flames
and then you work for a half hour on
this little project that's it at the end
of a week you've done
two and a half hours or at the end of
two weeks you've done a lot and
and it's that that is that that little
bit a lot goes a long way over over a
period of time too and you're not really
interfering with the works at all um and
i try to tell people to do that also um
if you can't if we don't have time or
everything else you know do that
that's the first thing you should do
before you even do anything else is you
know grow a little bit
yeah i love that i love putting it first
too um
yeah i used to have other hobbies that i
would try to do mostly failing but i was
trying to do at the beginning of the day
because you always have energy at the
beginning of the day
jairus i asked you if you had a meeting
to go to and then i did a bad job of
listening for the answer of that
do you have time for one more question i
can do one more question okay
i saw that i missed the question from
chris earlier sorry about that um but it
was when we were talking about modeling
it was what are you using for your
modeling today
um sorry can you repeat it it was what
are you using for your model
is that like is this around packages or
yeah yeah
gotcha forecast is what we use for a lot
of stuff um we've tried to implement
profit as well with mixed success again
we're doing a lot of time series work um
so those are the ones we generally rely
on um and then
um
for plotting i think we're still doing
gg plot for a lot of stuff and honestly
this is probably a better question for
my team because i have not been in in
the uh the code as much as of late but
uh yeah that then bigquery connectors as
well um but yeah forecast is the one we
rely on and i see uh steven saying yeah
profit is not great looks like he had a
sort of similar experience we brought it
online for some questions and it did not
deliver his pro promise but forecast and
then again human in the loop you know
where necessary um is
profit gets tracked hard on data science
linkedin
yeah so forecast is the one we've had
the most successful
awesome thank you so much jairus this
has been so fun i really appreciate your
time and sharing your insights with all
of us
yeah thanks for having me and thanks for
showing up everyone it was really great
to see you and chat with you it's been a
lot of fun
yeah and if anyone has follow-up
questions for you or what's the best way
to get on contact is it linkedin
yeah i think linkedin or twitter um yeah
those work
awesome well thank you all have a great
rest of the day hopefully see you next
week
you